some more examples subtracting decimals
so let's say we want to figure out what
2 minus 1.2 is pause this video and see
if you can calculate this so there's
multiple ways to tackle this one way is
you could say look this is the same
thing as 2 minus 1 2 minus 1 minus 2 10
this is 2 minus 1 and 2 tenths so you
were subtracting 1 and we're subtracting
2 tenths now 2 minus 1 is pretty
straightforward to compute 2 minus 1 is
going to be 1 and then we need to
subtract two tenths from that so 1 is
the same thing as 10 tenths we could say
this is this is 10 10 10 right this way
ten tenths and we're going to subtract
two tenths what is that going to give us
well that's going to give us with 10
tenths and we take away two tenths
that's going to give us 8 tenths let me
write it down here 8 tenths which is the
same thing as 0.8 or eight tenths one
way to think about this is if you're
subtracting 0.2 from one if you view
this if you view this one as a 1.0
instead of expressing this as 1 1 and 0
tenths we are thinking about this as 0 1
and 10 tenths and when you think about
it is 0 ones and 10 tenths well 10 10 to
minus 2 tens it's easier to then take oh
and think about what kind of something -
2 of something it's going to be a -
something's going to be 8 tenths now we
can also visualize this on a number line
so for example let me draw a number line
here and so 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
that's 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 that is 2 so
we're starting at 2 and we're
subtracting 1 & 2 tenths so one way to
think of
is we first subtracted one we first
subtracted 1 and then we subtracted 2/10
and that got us to the point 8 tenths on
the number line another way to think
about this and the whole point here is
to see multiple strategies and for you
to think about what strategy you like
the most and to realize they all get you
to the same place if you're thinking
about it in a reasonable way is you
could use what's the difference between
2 and 1 point 2 so 1 point 2 sits here
on the number line so what's the
difference between 2 & 1 & 2 tenths
another way to think about it is how
many tenths do you have to add to 1 & 2
tenths to get to 2 well if you've
already got two tenths you need to add
another 8 tenths to get to the next hole
so you have to add 8 tenths or you have
to add 0.8 so the difference between 2 &
1 point to the difference between 2 & 1
point 2 is equal to 0.8 let's do a few
more examples that get a little bit more
involved so let's say we want to
calculate what 3 point 8 minus 1.5 is
pause the video and see if you can
calculate this well just like before we
could view this as 3 minus 1 so we're
subtracting the ones plus 8 tenths minus
5 tenths minus minus 5 tenths minus 5
tenths
notice we have three and eight tenths
three and eight tenths minus one and
five tenths minus 1 and minus five
tenths and so now we can figure out ok 3
minus 1 that's just going to be equal to
two and then eight tenths minus five
tenths
well that is three tenths and so this is
going to be two and three tenths which
of course we could write as 2 to point 3
that seems pretty straightforward let's
do one that's a little bit more involved
let's say you want to calculate 4 & 5
tenths or 4 point 5 minus
two and eight tenths or 2.8 pause the
video and see if you can calculate this
so you might want to do the exact same
thing you might say okay well this is
the same thing let's talk about the ones
this is four minus two plus five tenths
plus five tenths minus eight tenths
minus 1/10 four and five tenths
four and five tenths minus two and minus
8 tenths minus two and 8/10 that's
exactly what we have up here and you
would say all right 4 minus 2 that is 2
but then you get to five tenths minus
eight tenths and there's multiple ways
to tackle this but you might say well
how do I take away eight tenths if I've
only got five tenths here and there's a
bunch of strategies that you could think
about you could say hey what if I can
get some more tense here so this is five
tenths five tens minus eight eight
tenths what if I could get some more
tense here the best way I could think of
it is like what if I were to break up
these ones because one is ten tenths so
I could view a two I could view a 2 as 1
plus one or I could view this as 1 plus
10 10 10 10 so if your view a 2 is 1 and
10 tenths you can then just add those
you could then figure out what is 10
tenths plus 5 tenths plus 5 tenths minus
8 tenths minus 8 minus 8 tenths what is
that going to be well this is a little
bit more straightforward ten tenths plus
five tenths is going to be 15 tenths and
if you have 15 1010 you take away eight
of them you're going to be left with
seven tenths so this gets us to one plus
seven tenths so all of this when you
compute it that is seven tenths
which I could write as 0.7 which is
equal to so this is equal to 1 1 and 1
and 7/10
now there's other strategies that you
could do here one strategy that this is
the one that I typically do in my head
is I write this as 4 point 5 minus 2
point 5 minus 2 point 5 minus 0 point 2
3 or 4 and 5/10 minus 2 and 5/10 minus
3/10 now why did I write it this way
because I find this pretty
straightforward to compute and then once
I get that answer I just have to take
away 3/10 so for example well if I have
5/10 here and I'm taking away 5/10 those
are going to knock each other out and
sewed I'm just going to be left with 4
minus 2 which is going to be 2 and then
I have to take away the 3/10 then I have
to take away the 3/10 so this is a
pretty straightforward way of doing it
in your head
so what's 3 tenths less than 2 well you
can visualize a number line in your head
well that's going to be 1 and 7/10 1 and
7/10
and if this feels strange how I got a
107 hundreds 1 and 7/10 and that this
seems strange how I got there that fast
just think about this this is the same
thing as 1 plus 1 minus 3/10 and this
one right over here is the same thing as
10 tenths and so 10 tenths minus 3/10
that over there is going to be that is
going to be 7/10 so it's going to be 1 &
7 tenths which is what we got before so
the whole point here is to appreciate
there's multiple strategies for
subtracting decimals some that you can
do a little bit more automatically but
it's really good to think about what's
going on in your head and some
strategies are actually better in your
head than on paper or at least more easy
in your head